hello everyone I'm Ilana welcome to my
channel this is I chose the office is a
background Stanley because I'm not at
home during quarantine so I can't use my
nice distracting ultrawide monitor and
rainbow keyboard as a background hope
everyone staying safe staying home and
welcome to yeah it's a first party of
the month so it's another Q&A I really
[ __ ] that up shams or reigns do you
think vo will become an essential for
every game by the year 2025 in gaming as
we know it today will be completely
changed by then I don't know that VR
will be an essential for every game
honestly ever because there are some
obvious limitations people don't like
being in VR for a long time is a very
big one gaming can still be very social
you can still want to play something in
your living room with the surrounding of
your living room visible to you for
comfort purposes also that other people
can see we are doing or so you can look
at your phone at the same time or have
something else happening at the same
time I don't think VR is ever going to
be 100% of how we play video games I do
maintain that via is going to become a
lot more popular than it is right now
and it is going to be a lot more of a
household staple as soon as it becomes
actual wireless video and as soon as it
got significantly cheaper because right
now it is kind of prohibitively
expensive especially for something that
really only one person can use at a time
do I think
gaming as we know today will be
completely changed by 2025 yes I think
there are still major changes coming to
the video game industry honestly right
now video games on even in their teenage
years yet the industry so young it's
basically like a little baby industry
that's doesn't even know how to speak
yet I think right now a lot of games are
still just trying to emulate movies in a
lot of ways with some interactive
elements we don't know what video games
completely independently of other
mediums even look like yet I think it's
gonna be pretty dramatic
hey sim one $1.99 set do you have a Miss
buntings snags yeah dude uh Bunning
snags my stepdad went to Bunnings maybe
like last month and was complaining and
I like family group thread thing we have
that they didn't have any onions that
day so huge moment maybe the quality's
gone down since I left
chicca Becca said how is the eczema your
general health and Quarantine doing
eczema still still shitty my hands are
okay now though it's a [ __ ] but it's
fine
really that is not a huge problem in the
grand scheme of problems that exists my
general health actually right now is
very good I don't know if I mentioned
this last time but I haven't fainted
once in 2020 which is a big a deal that
I feel like I may be let on
lost yeah like there was one time where
I fainted and I hit my head on my
bathroom sink and then I blacked out for
several hours and had conversations I
had no recollection off and then there
was another time that I fainted on my
staircase and had this huge bruise on my
butt for a really long time and I got
this like honestly genuinely mine of
phobia of staircases which I know sounds
insane but I was like if I had to hit my
head that would have been so much worse
but thankfully I felt kind of down at
backwards so for me that's very exciting
Florentine because I can't actually
still do so much of what I do I'm
actually doing just fine playing a lot
of video games
honestly like compared to a lot of other
people doing really well one thing that
I've found to be quite hard is just that
my family is really far away I'm still
in California they're in Australia so
that's definitely a very anxious thing
I'm sure anyone who separated from their
families you know by flights that at
some point might get cancelled
it's scary [ __ ] but we're just talking a
lot so I'm just like making effort to
talk to them all the time as much as
possible really
Morgan bunch of said if you could only
have one condiment for the rest of your
life what would it be
mayonnaise [ __ ] I am a white girl so yo
Laura said are you still at fun house
yes I am if you're noticing that I'm in
videos less at fun house it is because
the amount of hours that I work changed
because it sort of had to in late
october last year i stopped working at
fun house full-time and moved to a
contract position and that happened
because i needed to take that huge step
back to improve my health and I do feel
like I've been really candid about that
and when people have austie been like
yeah I took a step back and overall it
has worked out super well because I am
doing very well health-wise right now
and thankfully they were okay with me
doing it otherwise I honestly probably
would have just had to flat out quit
because it just got to a point where it
it wasn't an option anymore I had to do
it so I think people are getting in part
also confused about that right now
because over the last two weeks I've
been making more content on
my own and that is because I'm feeling
all better so the reason that I've
started doing more on my own channel
rather than just increasing the amount
that I'm on funhaus is because the
company structure changed this is like
very inside baseball to explain but
basically when I went contract other
people stepped up to me on camera my
like Lindsey and John for example who
you would have seen more of recently I
can't just show up and be like I feel
better put me on camera again it just
doesn't work that way it's also just not
efficient to approach anything
business-related like that with that
amount of like bullheadedness now that I
am doing a lot better I mean I don't
want to just run into content
immediately and just get myself sick all
ever gonna kind of want to do it slowly
but I do have the intention of being on
camera more but to cover the hell out of
the answer to this question I definitely
still work at front house I have not
left
I did go contract because I had to which
is why I started appearing on camera or
less cuz I was working a lot less hours
and I am feeling a lot better now which
is why I'm making a lot more content on
my own because I have the time to do it
and I also need money I took a dramatic
pay cut in order to you know take that
time off for my health because health is
obviously more important than money but
though it may take a while I should
start being in more content pretty soon
to 807 Djoser besides video games what
other publications have you written for
also what's your favorite sport to watch
or play in university I did some court
reporting naturally I studied journalism
so that involves going to a court taking
notes on basically the proceedings and
then putting together a story about that
I've done a lot of toy coverage because
I was originally actually hired at IGN
as a toys and culture editor not as like
anything to do with gaming there are
actually very few roles that are very
specific to just covering gaming
naturally I also did that a lot but that
was my first job was actually the toys
and culture editor which meant I was
covering a lot of toys I was covering a
lot of cosplay and I was also covering
science which was always my favorite
thing to write about but a while ago I
also was the editor of a car website
small [ __ ] culture coverage then like
breaking news but basically it's
showcasing a lot of people who had
really cool builds or going to events a
lot of stuff like that when it comes to
sports to watch or play I played a lot
of sports in in school I did water polo
I played netball I played basketball I
did triathlons I played soccer and I
also did just a lot of swimming
but that's not you know that much but
you just use this swimming really I
still swim sometimes
favorite sports to watch I really like
AFL I love hockey I've been to maybe
five or six hockey games since I moved
to the US and I find that so fun to
watch in pot because you have these
professional athletes on ice which
naturally makes you a little uncommon of
course they're very coordinated on ice
but then they stop throwing punches at
each other because for some reason in
hockey that's allowed and so you have
professional athletes on ice just
slipping around like idiots trying to
hit each other it's incredible a big fan
of hockey but I also watch a fair amount
of Premier League football yeah the end
say what kind of student were you like
in high school / college hard-working
goody two shoes are just carefree about
school
absolutely 5050 I love doing assignments
and always have because I love writing
so much so any assignment that I had I
would go hard and do you know my two
thousand words and researched the hell
out of it and get my bibliography
perfect didn't like you I got very good
grades for that kind of stuff
I also refused to do any science or
mathematics based subjects because I did
not enjoy them and was already
stubbornly as a teenager like it's fine
I know I'm gonna end up being a writer
what do I care about these subjects I
hate myself for that now because I think
physics is very interesting and also
Jesus I'm so bad at maths it's my own
fault
I just didn't take advantage of that
part of the education system because I
had the option to not I had to pass just
very basic maths but I didn't take any
extension man so there's a lot of stuff
about that that I don't know that I was
very stupid to be like I don't need that
but yeah generally I was not at all the
goody two-shoes I think the teachers
probably would have found me smart but I
wasn't a kiss-ass by any means but I did
do my work when I needed to for grades
at any other point in time like homework
I phoned it in unless I found it
interesting red foam and ice will you
ever become a United States citizen I do
not ever intend to but even if I did
intend to which genuinely I don't I
would have to tell you that I don't
intend to because part of the basically
clothes of me renewing my
visa easily is that I have to have no
intention of staying here permanently
Henry said thoughts on Simpson whether
they exist I have two minds Supes
definitely exists but it also feels like
just another word to use as an excuse to
tell people not to be nice to women on
the Internet so half half sometimes
someone will say something that I think
is written with absolutely no intention
of fondling my bosoms but because I'm a
woman in there and then they get told
they're a simp and I think that that
stuff is shitty
Jeremy parsley said what's your favorite
Studio Ghibli film and why my favorite
Ghibli film is polka Rosa something
about that film that I just find Murray
like uplifting and majestic and creative
but while still being and grounded it's
not too dark and it's not too fantastic
it just strikes this balance that I find
extremely pleasant I really like polka
Rosa
oh my 2330 is my cue for April how do
embargoes work is information about them
also embargoed as a not you allowed to
say I'm playing X Y Z but I can't tell
you about it until the embargo lifts on
whatever date who sets embargo is PR
marketing fellows production all others
the different companies have good bad
reputation for how they deal with press
info goes sometimes embargoes embargoed
yes like for example I just streamed
resident evil 3 and you one allowed to
announce that U is streaming resident
evil 3 until an hour before 4 a.m.
Pacific time that day I think so yeah
there is generally a date in which you
can tell people you have the game even
if you have it a lot earlier than that
death stranding was a really really
really particular one and then there is
a date where you can tell people when
reviews are going live so yes embargoes
are embargoed embargoes also sometimes
include information it's like no matter
what you're never allowed to talk about
this you're never allowed to show this
do not post this in a review or any
gameplay of this section because a lot
of the time they're very conscious of
avoiding spoilers which I'm totally in
support of I think embargoes are
generally set by PR or marketing and
maybe a combination of the two because
it is a combination of those two things
but I highly doubt any dev or anyone in
production has any hand in it and yes
different companies do have different
reputations for how they deal with press
and in photos
sony has a reputation of being extremely
strict when it comes to how they deal
with press and like a little bit panicky
I mean Konami has a reputation for
blacklisting people Nintendo can be
really hard to get codes from they also
have really strict embargoes you can be
blacklisted for a lot of things with
Nintendo
yeah people have different reputations
for sure official the the biggest thing
that you care about as media when it
comes to embargoes is how quickly you
can get the game before the game comes
out because that dictates how much you
need to play to be able to review the
thing in however much time you have so
if someone has an embargo the day after
you get the game you probably gonna be a
little bit mad at them and that is it
for me today everyone thank you all for
the questions like I said I'd leave it
with more questions in the comments
below for the next video stay safe for
everyone